[Musique]
lentement sans visages émergent de ce
grand bloc de marbre ramener tout
spécialement de carrare yanek le
sculpteur dégagent les traits de léonard
de vinci et ce buste c'est une cockpit
qui viendra remplacer l'original du 19e
siècle très dégradé au château d'amboise
là où repose le corps du maître de la
renaissance
pour yannick ce travail c'est tout un
symbole
c'est émouvant et parce qu'il a un
visage strict avec des traits
caractéristiques et puis c'est un
personnage qu'on connaît depuis notre
enfance
depuis deux ans tant que sculpteur oui
c'est vrai que c'est énorme au lycée sur
un repère une référence pour ce
sculpteur spécialisé dans la
restauration les du patrimoine à
restaurer dans la région et dans
manquent pas
[Musique]
aujourd'hui yannick se rend à rigny ussé
la légende veut que ce château soit
celui de la belle au bois dormant et
c'est lui qui est chargé de restaurer
les lucarnes de cette façade typique de
la renaissance finissante les deux
lucarnes du milieu sont un style assez
proche donc on devrait logiquement
retrouver le meilleur de la nature on a
les deux anges à la place des deux
sauvages on a le blason au milieu
exactement les mêmes dimensions et c'est
vrai que c'est assez semblable au niveau
du décor c'est un château qui est très
richement décoré il a eu des
propriétaires très fortunés au moins de
la renaissance qui ont pu faire un
travail admirable mais ça demande
beaucoup de restauration surtout que
c'est du tuffeau qu'est une pierre
locale qui est plus friable que des
pierres qu'on trouve dans beaucoup
d'endroits et donc c'est vrai si vous
regardez ce qui n'a pas été restaurée
souvent les pierres il reste pas grand
chose et pour conserver cette marque
d'authenticité les travaux de
restauration doivent s'appuyer sur une
documentation aussi précise que possible
voilà donc là on a le livre de gagnières
dans lesquels on retrouve les gravures
de 1699 où on a notamment un très beau
dessin des blasons les lucarnes qu'on
est en train de refaire ça c'est blason
qu'il faut reprendre pour les bouquins
je vous enverrai une photo où elle est
très bien faite aux copies que je vous
enverrai pour la lucarne pour le mois de
juin
[Musique]
on retrouve yanek dans son atelier c'est
ici que chacune des pièces de la fameuse
lucarne de rigny ussé travail est donc
là c'est les outils du sculpteur voilà
ses ciseaux et déboucha bas pour le bois
qu'on utilise pour la pierre parce que
la pierre et à s'étendre dans la région
pour qu'on puisse travailler comme pour
le bois
la période romane on reste beaucoup dans
l'est dans la géométrie du bloc originel
alors que dans la renaissance on va
essayer d'oublier en fait on va essayer
de l'oublier l'architecturé on va faire
vraiment on va donner vraiment s'appelle
une place très importante à naturel donc
il faut faire en sorte que le feuillage
et l'air d'être naturel faut essayer de
retrouver un petit peu l'état d'esprit
du sculpteur mais on fait du mieux qu'on
peut quoi le petit village de preuilly
sur claise est aujourd'hui bien paisible
il fut longtemps considérée comme l'une
des plus importantes baronnie de
touraine en ce début d'après midi une
vingtaine d'habitants se sont réunis
dans la chapelle de tous les saints une
chapelle funéraire du 15e siècle qui a
bien failli à plusieurs reprises
disparaître
[Musique]
après guerre la chapelle était j'ai vu
des photos de l'époque a été entièrement
couverte de lierre
le toit était percée tout s'écroulait
redécouverte presque par hasard dans les
années 50 elle fut aussitôt placée sous
une couche d'enduit on ya découvert un
ensemble de fresques exceptionnel sur le
thème de la danse macabre de
spécialistes des décors muraux vient
aujourd'hui les expertiser et l'état de
ses chefs-d'oeuvre est très préoccupant
les deux problématiques majeures
ça a été les décollements d'enduit comme
on voit ici dû aux problèmes
d'infiltration qui a eu qui ont donc
décoller les couches d'enduit et donc de
décor et la deuxième donc ce sont les
trous de piquetage qui ont été faits par
l'homme et qui donc ont ruiné la surface
général et qu'il va falloir reprendre
ce personnage de la chapelle a été
reproduit à l'identique une cinquantaine
de kilomètres plus loin sur le site de
muro dell'arte un conservatoire dédié à
la recherche et à la transmission du
savoir faire de l'art mural dans cette
grange les restaurateurs peuvent quitter
steller méthode avant de les appliquer à
la fresque historique
là je suis en train de dégrader un
fragment de décors tels qu'ils
pourraient être dégradées afin de
pouvoir faire des essais de nettoyage et
de consolidation dessus le bâtiment
étant du xviiie siècle
il a des pathologies qui se sont
intégrés comme des remontées de celle de
l'humidité et ça nous permet nous de
pouvoir en posant des copies de décor
dans les techniques de chaque période
ça nous permet de voir comment les
pathologies sont générés sur ses décors
en quelques semaines ou quelques mois
on va aussi regarder la couche picturale
ici qui est assez pulvérulente par
exemple si je viens touché la peinture
on voit que le pigment reste sur mon
doigt ça c'est une des pathologies qu'on
avait découverte à prier sur claise dans
la chapelle de tous les saints et qu'on
a voulu reproduire
justement ici pour voir comment on
allait refixer c'est qu'ici on a
retrouvé les gestes et usages de
toujours terminer les substances
chimiques place aux produits naturels
dans nos recherches
on en est venu à comprendre que ce sont
les meilleurs les meilleures méthodes ce
sont les méthodes ancestrales
donc on en est revenu à ça on a
recherché ces méthodes entrée
ancestrales et on a retravaillé dessus
évidemment on a fait à nouveau des tests
et on a recréé une méthodologie
[Musique]
pour un monument aussi emblématique que
chambord
on sait que les travaux d'entretien et
de restauration peuvent s'avérer délicat
et parfois même polémique
pas de problème particulier pour ceux
actuellement menés sur le mur d'enceinte
ils s'inscrivent dans le cadre de
travaux programmés
bonjour tout est lié à l'état sanitaire
du qui va ressortir en fait de l'étude
de l'architecte en chef
le programme que nous faisons sur dix en
effet en collaboration avec la maîtrise
d'ouvragé l'architecte en chef des
monuments historiques et le crm h le
conservateur régional des monuments
historiques et donc la priorité va se
faire du coup sûr les hassani terres qui
sont plus dégradées
parfois les choix sont plus contestées
retour sur une polémique qui a enflammé
historia et gaz est cependant plusieurs
mois
en cette année 2010 9,9 énormes
chantiers sont prévus pour commémorer
les 500 ans du monument jean
d'haussonville son directeur souhaite
redorer le sommet des lanternes
ont-elles qu'on suppose qu'ils furent en
15/100 39
lorsque françois 1er a cueilli son rival
charles k ce projet est un projet
cohérent complet rigoureux destiné à
magnifier le monument et a retrouvé le
premier chambord voulu par françois 1er
problème les documents sur lesquels
s'appuient jean d'haussonville s'avère
extrêmement minces il n'y a aucune vue
de chambord à cette époque qui
montreraient des dorures
on ne sait pas exactement comment
étaient les lanternes à l'époque il faut
savoir que d'internautes et et refaire
entre temps on ne sait pas quel était
l'état de chambord à cette époque là sa
charte de venise applique qu restant
dans le dernier état historiques connus
là on est dans l'invention complète
articles de presse avis négatif de la
commission des monuments historiques
intervention du président de la
république qui finit par faire machine
arrière
sachant son projet recalé le directeur
de chambord ans représentent une
nouvelle version limitée cette fois ci
au décor de plomb seule une girouette
sera finalement recouverte du métal
précieux
au delà de cette polémique ce sont de
vraies questions qui se posent sur ce
que peut être une restauration réussie
cette histoire est symptomatique de du
fait que d'un côté le patrimoine on en
parle beaucoup mais de l'autre côté on
en parle mal et on comprend pas ce que
c'est que patrimoine
le patrimoine a besoin d'argent a besoin
sur des compétences et a besoin de
décisions pour éviter qu'on le détruise
pour qu'on le restaure le touriste est
extrêmement important pour patrimoine
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui crée de la
richesse mais faire venir des touristes
pour de mauvaises raisons
ça va pas sauver le patrimoine au
contraire ça va le détruire et il ya un
côté disneyland
ok le même qu'à versailles où on fait
revenir les gens et du doré du clinquant
du léonard de vinci en veux tu en voilà
le patrimoine ça suscite l'émotion la
passion et donc c'est normal que les
débats soient passionnés dès qu'on parle
de l'or c'est spectaculaire on imagine
que c'est très coûteux que c'est
somptuaires que ça n'est jamais
nécessaire alors que bien sûr dans
l'évocation de laure il y avait à la
fois le désir d'évoquer le chambord d'il
ya cinq cents ans d'en donner une
interprétation mais aussi de donner une
image d'une fierté nationale qui puisse
rayonner à travers le monde bien sûr que
je regrette un peu
l'évocation de laure mais je pense que
finalement la solution trouvée elle est
pacifique apaisante
elle est largement soutenue et c'est
très important si pour chambord fin de
la discorde le site historique peut
retrouver sa quiétude et ses touristes
[Musique]
c'est un bien étrange visiteurs qui
arpentent les allées du château
kevin bec des chercheurs à l'université
d'orléans sa spécialité les maladies du
faux alors évidemment chambord constitue
un excellent terrain pour ses recherches
dans un programme de recherche qui a été
financée par la région centre il ya
quelques années nous avons établi une
cartographie de cette zone et on sait
pierre à pierre qu'elles sont la
datation des pierres la provenance de
ces pierres et leur nature d'altération
un véritable carnet de santé du monument
exactement comme on pourrait le faire
pour un patient c'est que les maladies
de cette pierre sont nombreuses
la pierre de tuffeau qui est ici on est
certain qu'elle est d'époque montcalm
date du 16e siècle
c'est la pierre d'origine du château de
chambord et cette pierre je la subis une
desquamation assez importante qu'une
perte de plaques ici là et une paire de
matière sur à peu près 2 à 3 cm
d'épaisseur
là je suis en train de faire un
prélèvement de pierres dans la zone
fissuré afin de finaliser après en
laboratoire je cherche à savoir si on a
la présence de deux polluants à
l'intérieur pierre qui pourrait
expliquer cette fissuration retour au
laboratoire les précieux prélèvements
vont être broyés pile est soigneusement
observé
[Musique]
entre ça sert de faire cette recherche
de cristaux notre but c'est de faire une
détection pour séparer les minéraux qui
sont naturellement présents dans la
pierre en gros une pierre sennes des
minéraux qui sont extérieurs à la pierre
dont qu'il vient d'une pollution d'une
source de pollution extérieure la pierre
de tuffeau a des qualités essentielles
pour la renaissance au niveau de sa
blancheur sa légèreté et son peule a
sculpté facilement mais elle est aussi
très poreuse et très sensible par
rapport à l'altération par rapport à son
environnement
donc il est nécessaire de la surveiller
de faire un bon entretien de cette
pierre afin d'augmenter au plus sa durée
de vie et dans ce rôle de conseil
les scientifiques sont irremplaçables à
tour dans ce beau bâtiment du 16e siècle
il règne comme une ambiance de start up
ici les ordinateurs tournent à plein
régime réalité virtuelle modélisation 3d
les monuments comme chambord sont passés
à la moulinette numérique intelligence
et patrimoine c'est une école un
programme de recherche est un incubateur
créé notamment par le centre d'études de
la renaissance et l'université de tours
sur cet écran si vous avez en fait un
produit dérivé de l'acquisition
scientifique qui est en fait une version
affiché sur le web en temps réel d'une
sculpture qui est là une vierge à
l'enfant de blois en terre cuite et là
l'intérêt pour nous c'était vraiment de
donner aux gens la possibilité de
manipuler de voir l'objet avec sa
texture en fait sa matière et a rendu
physique de la matière qui donne une
bonne perception de ce qu'est l'objet en
réalité une expérience virtuelle ludique
et donc un plus pensé pour les touristes
mais pas seulement
ça permet aux restaurateurs d'avoir des
données qui sont des données de
vraiment extrême qualité et donc un
travail ensuite de précision pour la
restauration soit en amont pour la
connaissance même de l'objet soit en
aval pour justement pouvoir le traiter
et le restaurer
la haute technologie au service du
patrimoine et si loin du clinquant ces
outils de connaissance permettait de
réconcilier les intérêts du tourisme et
ceux des acteurs de la restauration une
chance peut-être pour redonner sens et
lisibilité à un patrimoine si riche et
si fragile
[Musique]